that's some breaking news from new york
and a federal jury in brooklyn has
reached a verdict in the trial of the r
b singer ah kelly he was accused of sex
trafficking uh u.s correspondent martha
kelner joins me now so martha what was
the verdict
yeah just in the last couple of minutes
this jury of seven men and five women
here at the federal courthouse in
brooklyn new york has convicted r kelly
of racketeering the prosecution have put
forward the case over the past six weeks
here that r kelly an r b music star a
three-time grammy music award winner
presided over a criminal enterprise that
he used bodyguards runners and security
staff in order to facilitate his
lifestyle of sexually abusing more than
20 girls boys and women over the course
of two decades it's taken this jury nine
hours five hours of deliberations today
four hours of deliberations um on friday
last week to reach the verdict that r
kelly is guilty of racketeering he now
faces between 10 years and life in
prison and the judge is still reading
out the charge sheet he was charged with
nine separate offenses by federal
prosecutors here in brooklyn but
racketeering was the most serious
offense of which he was charged and of
that this jury has found him guilty
just to give you an idea of some of the
incredibly disturbing testimony that
this jury has had to listen to over the
past six weeks women have taken the
stand women and boys have taken the
stand and to say that that whilst they
were having sexual relations with r
kelly he would keep them locked in rooms
for days on end that they would have to
get his permission even to go to the
toilet that he would beat them if he
deemed that they had disobeyed him it
really has been
incredibly incredibly disturbing
testimony we're still waiting to hear
whether our kelly
real name robert kelly is in fact guilty
of kidnapping and the other offense of
crossing state lines for the purposes of
prostitution some of his fans are here
he still does have a handful of fans
here protesting his innocence the news
just filtering through to them though
that he's been found guilty of the most
serious charge of racketeering in this
trial that's lasted six weeks now